hey guys gamespot gameplay here with our
first 16 minutes playing agents of
mayhem in this intro mission we meet the
agents as they storm a legion base to
steal dr. babylons warhead from what
you've seen so far what do you think of
agents of mayhem let us know in the
conversation below and give us a sub to
stay tuned for our agents of mayhem
reveal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
activate cooking
they're ready when you are Persephone
they are in the briefing room yes ma'am
Hollywood fortune and heart tag or all I
know who I asked for Friday of course
you know there is one small matter I'd
like is quick it's personal and you know
what not important we'll talk later
this is a dark matter warhead it is
capable of dismantling reality itself
never mind the loss of life and property
and it is the brainchild of this man dr.
Babylon the head of legions Ministry of
bride I'm sure you've heard me speak of
him we have tracked both to a facility
beneath Seoul South Korea your objective
is twofold agents one steal the warhead
to kill dr. Babylon you three will go in
separately Hollywood draw all of the
bases attention to you
hardtack while they're distracted take
out the facility's security system and
fortune you'll steal their warhead
precisely no questions
good
[Music]
I'm in position
Roger that I am too well then see you
all on the flip side flips lock agents
be saved
[Music]
[Music]
sound of thing shot it I'm in all
available health troopers we have a
situation in the southwest quadrant
[Music]
[Music]
cue the action music
well this party is dead you're quoting
one of your movies aren't you a first
off fortune it was a film on a movie but
you recognize that huh let's focus on
the job
holy [ __ ] I think I found D Babs
chemistry set
hold on I'll shut it down real quick Oh
what do you mean Oh Oh what happened I
think I made the glowing ball angry
glowing ball as in a giant evil ball of
death
that's a Dominator Hollywood D Babs
Dominator death that's a lot of bad
sounding D words hold on I see a console
well [ __ ]
that didn't work think Hollywood line
dammit what happened I poked the bear I
poked the bear Jew kid what I kind of
shot the evil ball the thing is at peak
[ __ ] Bullock your Dark Matter energy
man shoot don't shoot look I don't have
time line knows we're here now
good going woody enough just get to the
rendezvous point
all right I'm at the rendezvous
I love kicking légion ass you all this
psyched as I am ready and waiting Tech
just need you to check out these turrets
no problem critical systems failing
you should be clear for it all away in
now thanks jack troopers I command a
status report
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] it up don't don't you
numerous internal and external defenses
could someone just walk in here you guys
here in deep apps he is pissed off the
guy's always pissed off anyone know why
Persephone is such a hate on for this
guy other than his being one of the bad
guys let's not forget that our boss used
to be one of the bad guys - I'm with
Hollywood where you have fortune
damn nice job on those tourist deck hey
yeah
so we got a situation in the southwest
cargo bay damn it this is only my first
day there you are my pretties just need
to take out a couple find a house first
just need a second to activate the lift
and here comes some bad guys these
rank-and-file chumps I don't think so
just hold tight I'll meet up with you in
a sense
[Music]
[Music]
that was a nice diversion but now back
to stealing [ __ ]
what has there been a breach in my lair
and up call the goods
sweet phase one done now on to phase two
[Music]
system failure detected
alright fellas let's go kill us a bad
doctor hell yeah
franchise force is back in action
franchise what now franchise force I
gave us a nickname okay just give
yourself a nickname such as me us
this will have already critical systems
failing
[Music]
[Music]
but Stephanie said this should be
easy-peasy you both ready mayhem
I should have known you fools
overcharging the Dominator core it's
something a child would do do you have
any clue as to how much danger you put
yourself in of course why are you even
here Persephone sending her dogs in to
do her dirty work and despite your
pathetic countering my plan is already
in motion
soon the Ministry of prime will be the
crown jewel in Legion IT Crowd we did
away with [ __ ] Babylon
do not fret though agent for I have a
final present for you I hope you got a
get with you just you way
once again mayhem you show no thought no
consideration you're only brutes with
bullets
isn't that right what is it they say
when all you have is a Hammer Every
Problem looks like a nail
farewell make unto you my sweet pet have
fun in your new home we gotta get out of
here
that think Babylon released was a point
thing dynamo write a zero point down in
wall and yeah it was if it gets out into
the city it is bad news I hope this
place is insured
no way I'm gonna kiss that dynamo moving
this slow porch see what you can do
I need time because of Hollywood [ __ ]
you don't hear pretty boy wait what why
me because you poke the bear
[Music]
later boss why
[Music]
nail it